[Musique]
ça fait une quinzaine d'années que
comprend l'achat local d'acheter le porc
du québec parce que on produit assez
peau pour alimenter l'ensemble du québec
les cochonnets de david duval font
partie des 750 5 millions de kilos de
viande porcine produites chaque année au
québec 70% de cette viande prendra le
chemin de l'exportation le cochon on
divise en plusieurs parties et il ya des
partis qui sont vraiment pour des
marchés spécifiques tels que nous on ne
consomme pratiquement pas il ya d'autres
partis qui sont plus à valeur ajoutée à
l'extérieur aussi au québec est ce
concours sont grosses et c'est du porc
haché des côtelettes des longes des
défilés après ça les autres partis c'est
un peu moins on va le faire on va le
manger en partie transformé celle du
jambon des choses comme ça le hic c'est
qu'on épicerie on ne trouve pas que du
porc du québec
votre fils et aux veaux côtelettes peut
venir des états unis du danemark ou de
l'allemagne
vautour tiers peuvent contenir du port
du brésil ou du mexique
pour le consommateur il est pratiquement
impossible de le savoir
lorsqu'on achète des co kr est emballé
par exemple des soucis sous à des quotas
doit pas pré emballé tout ça c'est plus
facile de savoir l'origine lorsque c'est
un pli emballages qui était fait à
l'usiné olymel ou prépa mais lorsque
s'est emballé en barquette à notre
boucherie de nos détaillants de notre
supermarché la semence est plutôt
difficile d'avoir l'information il m'est
arrivé personnellement de voir des
longes de porc qui était vraiment trop
grosse pour être des longes de porc du
québec certainement donc on parle
probablement de truies américaine puis
un prix dérisoire mais c'était pas un
disque et le stade seulement pour
indiquer ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
le marché mondial du port est un libre
marché
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pratiquement pas
de barrières tarifaires entre les pays
donc les distributeurs sont libres de
vendre où ils veulent et aux prix qu'ils
veulent nous sommes sur un prix us donc
à pas nécessairement de grande
différence entre le prix ht un port aux
etats unis une coupe
et puis l'acheter au canada donc il ya
des moments où elle était de moins cher
aux états unis donc on va aller la
chercher où il ya des moments où on veut
une certaine quantité des coupes
barbecue importe puis là on n'a
peut-être pas ce volume parce qu'on
avait déjà des contrats
d'approvisionnement de signer avec le
japon où peu importe
prix et disponibilité quand la demande
est forte pour telle ou telle pièce on
doit aller voir ailleurs on n'est pas
obligé d'importer du porc c'est une
question de coût et tire maintenant les
etats-unis ont une coupe qui est roi en
inventaire ils vont décider de la
vendent à rabais et à partir de mende à
ce moment là bas il ya des chaînes
d'épicerie qui ont décidé pour une scène
une scène la leaf dash est plutôt aux
états unis que d'acheter du québec c'est
au 5e seul c'est alors une question
d'offre et de demande les chaînes
d'alimentation place leurs commandes
les distributeurs voit ce qui est
disponible au meilleur prix puis signent
des ententes avec des fournisseurs
soient des abattoirs comme aliment
estaing du kamouraska nos chats
l'immense on priorise toujours le marché
local
quand je parle de marché local pour nous
c'est vraiment québec montréal et les
maritimes dons compris est restée
commande là puis avec ce qui reste c'est
sûr que c'est le produit qu'on
s'envoyait congélateur pour
l'exportation que ça dépend des contres
de provisionnement que nous
transformateurs ont avec le japon les
états unis la chine et ça dépend aussi
des délais avec eux nos grandes chaînes
peuvent aller négocier que ça regarde
toute la production qu'on fait au québec
la transformation qu'on fait au québec
surtout ça c'est impossible que le
marché québécois ou le marché canadien
assume toute cette baignant de douleur
dans le fond que les entreprises se sont
tournées vers l'exportation
mais rien de scandaleux dans ce marché
d'exportation et d'importation
selon le ministre andrée lamontagne mais
de façon générale si on regarde au
québec les
demandant par certains points 3 1 puis 4
milliards puis à peu près 70 millions $
qui vient de l'extérieur du canada
ben c'est exemple quand vous choisissez
votre bécane que vous voulez manger la
soupe rené dubé calme et poli
ben oui ça c'est comme importés au
québec et en ontario mais c'est comme un
portait sur poneys de bacon lafleur lui
est fait chez nous on exporte pour près
de 4 milliards de dollars de parts on en
importe pour des centaines de millions
donc ça ça met les choses en perspective
donc on exporte beaucoup plus que ce
qu'on n'est pas reste qu'ici on aime le
porc du québec
iga a pris l'engagement de ne vendre que
du porc du québec
au rayon des viandes fraîches mais il
n'en va pas de même pour les autres
chaînes ce qu'on cherche à faire
naturellement c'est encourager le plus
possible nos transformateurs à adhérer à
la marque aliments du québec
après ça il ya tout un côté promotionnel
aussi qu'on peut faire pour encourager
les gens à chercher les legault
d'aliments du québec
puis après ça les éleveurs de porc aux
autres ont déjà mettre en place
plusieurs volets promotionnelles et ont
même leur étiquette aussi le barreau du
québec et tout ça alors c'est tout et
comment s'est identifié puis comme on en
fait la promotion
mais il ya aucune réglementation qui
oblige décrire d'où provient le parent
qui se retrouvent à l'épicerie non ce
soit il est encore plus difficile de
trouver le logo aliments du québec sur
les aliments transformés plaisirs
gastronomiques et saint-hubert affirme
ne pas toujours avoir les volumes ni les
prix souhaités au québec
moi ça m'a déçu car je voyais que cette
cyber ou acheter du danemark et le
danemark lui il était pas capable de
transformer sa compte lever il a
vendaient à un prix de dumping leçons
sont produits le parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas capables de les couler sur le marché
européen en europe images pour sa déco
crever tu veux pas encore nous parler de
ta recette de longes de porc même pour
ya plein de bonnes raisons chose et le
pont de québec
ah oui on a fait un sondage et 80 pour
cent des personnes interrogées ont dit
que s'ils voient le sigle porcs du
québec ça les incite à acheter ce
produit là au lieu d'un autre
le gouvernement doit âgées en obligeant
peut-être d'un d'identifier douai douai
la provenance c'est pour ça qu'elle géo
la fête geo l'a fait parce que c'est
plié
lui ont dit nous c'est important que ce
soit des produits du québec on a une
excellente carte de visite dans tous les
autres pays à travers le monde au japon
là on voit des logos de compagnies
québécoises parce qu'ils sont fiers que
leur viande vient du québec vient du
canada
nous ce qu'on veut faire un en
augmentant la promotion la
conscientisation la des québécois envers
les produits locaux
on peut certainement encore amélioré
faire mieux de ce que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui
ouais je leur ai dit à chaque fois que
ce soit n'importe quel que ce soit le
walmart cosco nommer les tout cela
domaine citoyens il dit moi j'en achète
plus chez vous parce que ça vient pas du
québec
vous allez voir demain ils vont se
remettre à remettre de la viande porcine
du québec
[Musique]